hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar isolation of immune
cells using straight from microbeads
without density gradients I am Judy
o'rourke of laberd's and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by Milton E biotech
Milton E biotech is a global provider of
products and services that advance
biomedical research and cellular therapy
the company's innovative tools support
research at every level from basic
research to translational research to
clinical application this integrated
portfolio enables scientists and
clinicians to obtain analyze and utilize
the cell
Milton E biotechs technologies cover
techniques of sample preparation cell
isolation cell sorting flow cytometry
cell culture molecular analysis and
preclinical imaging there are more than
25 years of expertise spans research
areas including immunology stem cell
biology neuroscience and cancer in
clinical research areas like hematology
graft engineering and a phoresis to
learn more about Milton e biotech visit
wwl-tv biotech com let's get started you
can post questions to the speakers
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your mind to do so simply type
them into the drop down box located on
the far left of your screen labeled ask
a question and click on the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of the presentation window
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the answer a question box located on the
far left of your screen
this is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credit tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speakers Zhang Yu PhD
and Gregor winkles research scientist
Zhang joined Milton E biotech in 2016 as
a global product manager for the cell
separation reagents products in this
role she manages the launch and
marketing of new technologies in the
cell separation portfolio prior to
joining Milton E Zhang worked for pro
mega Benelux as a technical service
scientist and later as a product manager
for the cellular analysis and proteomics
portfolio supporting the Benelux and
Nordic branches since 2015
zhang has been the strategic
collaborations manager to promote pro
Megas emerging technologies gregor
winkles received his diploma as engineer
in biotechnology from the Aachen
University of Applied Sciences in
Germany he did his thesis on
characterization of blood dendritic cell
antigens at Milton Evo Tech where he
continued his work as a research
scientist on myeloid cells and novel
cell separation technology Gregor has
long term experience in separation
technologies immunology and antibody
generation as a group leader in R&D at
Milton II gregor is responsible for
myeloid cells separation product and
also new technological developments such
as these straight from and the max
Express cell isolation product lines
Zhang you and Gregor winkles will now
begin their presentations
hello my name is dawn you said global
product manager at Milton in biotech for
celebration region in today's webinar we
would like to introduce our new straight
for microbeads for immune cell isolation
without using density gradients
so in the first part of the presentation
I will introduce Milton biotech for
those that are not familiar with us and
also our selves separation portfolio
then my colleague Gregor winkles a group
leader in our Rd department who
developed the stress on microbeads with
his team will go in depth with a word on
our stretch from microbeads
not only biotech is a privately owned
company with its headquarters in Germany
with more than 20 with 2,000 employees
worldwide and with more than four about
500 of them working in our R&D
engineering department we try to advance
to develop tools for both basic
translational and clinical research
our headquarters is in Germany but we
are represented at worldwide in more
than 28 countries directly and the rest
of the world is served by our
distributors
we have over 11,000 products and with
those products we can support you in
your entire workflow for sample prep to
cell separation and cell analysis in
both the research and clinical area
so for those that are not familiar with
our max micro B technology I would like
to introduce first the basic principles
our Mac microbeads are around 50
nanometer size they are super para
magnetic particles conjugated to highly
specific antibodies
with these antibodies we can target
specific cell types together with the
max column which contains a matrix
composed of ferromagnetic spheres these
target cells are then captured using the
superparamagnetic particles together
with the max separators the columns have
a magnetic field that is M per fly
amplified by these separators by ten
thousandfold
so the target cells are captured in the
column and then separated from the on
target cells after a illusion of the
target cells we have our clean isolated
cells this is a fast and gentle
isolation method which can be done both
manually and with our instruments
just to give you an overview of our
maxed out separation regions we have
different portfolios and the and the
separating strategy can be both based on
different techniques so first of all we
have our Maps microbeads
this is based on the colors that I've
just introduced we use the light here
nano sized microbeads
and we have different types of
microbeads among others ultra pure and
reallys the starting material for these
max microbeads are single cell
suspensions and this is a positive
selection method
as a counterpart we have our max cell
isolation kids they these are also based
on columns and nano size but this is an
untouched isolation method which removes
the unwanted cells now in this webinar
we will talk about a straight from
microbeads
there are also based on columns and
lightness size microbeads however you
don't need to pre purify yourself you
can start immediately from blood
products such as whole blood puffy coats
and Luco packs as a counterpart we also
have our max microbeads they are based
on columns free technologies and have
micro-sized beads
so with this introduction after our
company in our cell separation reagent I
would like to handle for the microphone
to Gregor thanks some full introduction
hello Otto from my side my name is Kay
wrinkles and working in our D department
at the Medina biotech for more than
eighteen years now on the development of
separation reagent and I would like to
introduce to you today new portfolio of
separation reagents we developed for the
easy and fast direct cell isolation from
human blood sources so but let me first
start with a question how do you isolate
yourself interest from a whole lot basic
old LLC or Luca back so most of the time
I'm quite sure you used energy gradients
to get the PBMCs and to them and reach
for your cells of interest then but as
you all know delta T gradients that
separation protocol is a extremely
time-consuming process the transferred
and diluted samples must be laid onto a
gradient media before the centrifugation
appears and then the mono layer this
transfers into new vile platelet wash
must be performed and then the cells can
be counted before the received PBMCs can
be used and this whole process takes
usually more than two hours before you
have the cells of interest in hand so
the density gradient certification has
additional disadvantages and first and
most obvious is the loss of white blood
cells during the process we just talked
about the protocol and but you not only
have a lot of protocol there's only a
lot of hands-on time that you need to
spend and depending on the user you have
you also see variations and especially
when you have when all the blood samples
for example you not often get creepy VMC
layers new deformation of aggregates
appears and sometimes you
have uneven depletion of Traum besides
or Grandda besides so the discussion
about how harmful cycle is for cells we
don't want to start here but another
important point is that also the density
Guardian certification is not very
easily automated early so our intention
was to directly skip the density
gradient certification that you directly
are able to go straight from your source
of blood to the positive separation of
yourself of interest and this without
entity Guardians without cell counting
and so on so just short overview of the
different sound sources there are four
main sources which differ in the
concentration of pv mcs in blood for
whole blood the volume for sure was very
evident you have a low PBMC
concentration buffy coat normally comes
in the volume of 30 to 80 ml depending
on where you get your samples from have
the relatively high PB MC concentration
and is a waste product after blood
donation Lucas at reductions members
coming from platelet of rhesus samples
for example have the highest
concentration of P V MCS and very small
and highly dense concentration most of
the time between 10 and 15 and L ml and
the last but not least is Luca packs
where you have large stumble few MCS
usually seven times ten to the ninth at
all even up higher than 1 times 10 to
the 10 and the volumes extremely vary
depending on the vendor where you get
your sample from the can be fun 82 even
higher than 200 milliliters so let's
have a look at the workflow for our
straight form cell separation from Luca
pack the volumes that are set are
extremely depending on the vendor where
you get your sample from like there are
different vendors in the US for example
where one half of a local park is
sometimes is within 70 milliliters and
when you choose another one you have
them in up to 200 ml this must not be
the case with regard to the cell
concentration but this the total certain
almost more or less mostly depending or
the donor where you get the sample from
so what we did we configure the straight
home looking for isness reagents in a
way that you can start with harsh or
local freezes and you just need to
adjust the volume of your arteries to a
total volume of 200 milliliters and then
you need to add the complete content of
one vial of microbeads to the server
then you can incubate your samples for
15 minutes with the microbeads and then
the separation is done using multi 24
carbon block placed in the multi-max
device and this process usually only
takes 30 minutes meaning without density
gradient without cell counting no wash
after labeling you have yourself
interest within 30 minutes of time so
for sure you for the local park set for
separation you would need the multi mark
cell 24 separate applause this is a
really great device when you're working
with larger volumes or multiple samples
as we mostly do here and in combination
with the multi 24 color block there's
user-friendly handling of large volumes
extremely comfortable and the illusion
takes place there with an automated
vacuum station here you can process half
a local pack in a single run and then
the device also comes with a single
column adapter which allows you to
process also 1 2 up to 12 samples in
parallel with that and this would be
important for later reduced and for the
particle and analysis when we are
talking about this in case you are
looking for fully automated high support
systems we integrated the multi marks
into a liquid hinting system for high
speed processing and this is the multi
maxixe device
you
here you see now the separation of CD
form microbead from Luca park you see on
the left side the flow data for before
the separation showing the stained cd14
and c4 markers
cd4 for the T helper cells cd14 for
monocytes which also expressed at a low
level cd4 and you see on the right hand
after separation the highly pure T
helper cell population the table below
you see then the mean purity of this
separation this is a beam of eight
donors that has a very tight standard
deviation only with 2.7 percent and the
pewter is really great with 95 percent
the recovery with nearly 70 percent as
well as the yield for sure depends
mostly on the sample size and the donor
frequency of the cd4 positive cells an
additional example here for straight
from local park is the C 14 and which
meant you see here C D 15 standing where
the CD 1450 15 for the granulocytes
which might be problematic in case you
have all the samples for example and
sometimes you see in & Co enrichment
'since cd14 is also expressed at a low
level on granular side but using our
stretch one look apart reagents you see
here that after separation we only have
really is extremely tiny amount of C D
15 positive grando sites left mean
purity is again extremely great with
higher than 94% and and the mean
recovery with 56%
the yield as before for the cd4 cells
for sure Sibley is depending on the
donor where you get your samples from to
some the data for the local park
microbeads up you see in the dip for
different reagents we currently have so
we have cd4 cd8 cd14 and cd19 int you
see this slight variation in the purity
for CD aids depending on the number of
NKT cells which also Express cd8 and
deserts we gated for the accounting at
the estimation of the purity was only
the cd8 positive cytotoxic T cells you
see the recovery is really great you
have poor cd4 and cd8 positive cells
higher than 65 70 percent recoveries and
for cd14 and cd8 the recovery is good as
well
this data here I also wanted to share
with you as these ones are about
consecutive enrichment of more than once
a population out of one glucose ERISA's
so we all know how precious
leukapheresis samples are and therefore
we wanted to get most out of it and what
we did here was the enrichment of cd8
positive cells and we use negative
fraction for before washing the columns
for the subsequent enrichment of cd4 so
we meaning you simply take the negative
fraction label again and do CD for
enrichment and this works really well as
you can see here in the summary of the
data analysis you see that the purity of
cd8 positive cells is as before
94% but also for the cd4 cells in which
out of the negative fraction of the cd8
enrichment you see that the purity is
here good as well and that you only have
a minor contamination of cd8 positive
cells in the pores so when this means
that you can save precious material by
doing at least two consecutive
enrichments from one sample what I think
is extremely important
so just short wrap-up using the special
look of back mark awaits the use in
excellent purities and recoveries and it
allows also four consecutive enrichment
so we currently have four markers
available and one kit that what we offer
contains all components needed for the
adulation of selves from half a local
park so it contains the beads
it contains the multi twenty-four column
block and the whole blood dilution
buffer and for the manual to full
automation we also provide the multi
marks and 24 for the semi automated
separation in case you are interested in
high throughput and follow the
automation we would also have the multi
mark sakes so meaning that within 30
minutes from even sizes like half a
local park in a single run you get
yourself a Frenchman start
okay now switch the blood sources and
have a look at particle the volumes that
are contained within a barcode are also
a little bit depending on the
transfusion central blood bank where you
get them from the very mostly between 30
to 80 ml and what we decided was to make
cell preparation most convenient and
configurated the beats in a way that you
can use them without any cell counting
only by adjusting the content of your
body code with buffer to a volume of 80
ml then you simply take the content of
olive oil microbeads add them to your
body cold suspension and incubate 50
minutes without any washing steps
themselves can be applied on to the
magnetic columns we you see a hundred
columns placed in the magnetic field of
a magnet and with we need twelve columns
for the enrichment of a complete body
coat and we apply there 7 milliliters
per column and F's for the recovery the
samples as well here also we are done
within 30 minutes without any density
Guardian segregation with their
enrichment of yourself of interest
very briefly just a performance example
here again cd14 from one of the code you
see staining again on the y-axis cd14 on
the x axis CD 15 in this case you see
great purity with high recovers and even
from the body code you can get 2 times
10 to the 8th as out in this case
as a sum up of our body codes reagents
what we have at the moment cd4 cd8 cd14
cd19 and CD 56 you see the beauties are
all about 90% the recoveries and gears
which are good but for sure also depends
a little bit on the frequency in the
starting material and as before also
here for the Buffy coat reagents we have
possibility for consecutive separation
we developed at the moment markers for
the help of cells cytotoxic T cell cd44
the monocytes for the beasts at cd19 and
for the NK cells P 56 and similar to
what how we configure to also the kids
for the looking for rhesus we here also
provide well one kids which includes all
components or the isolation of cells
from one entire Buffy code meaning we
have the strike from particles
microbeads we have the whole bug columns
and we have the illusion buffers and
this you can this separation you can do
manual I have the quadrille marks or
using my t marks or what we prefers to
do to use the multi-max 7:24 all energy
mark six again only 30 minutes for
entire market code on a single run
that come to leukocyte reduction
chambers which are more involved used by
researchers as an eternity source of
white blood cells and within one of
these LLC's there are more than one
times ten to the nine the white blood
cells in ten to fifteen milliliters of
buffer and we results out of these LLC's
using syringes and peffern filters cell
suspension up to 40 milliliters before
we add them the content of one vial of
our straight from Alessi microbeads then
with this after this edition of the
microbeads within 50 minutes magnetic
labeling you can take the samples
directly and process them over the
magnetic columns and the multi-max one
quarter marks again 30 minutes without
density gradient centrifugation no cell
counting no wash after labeling things
here just sum up of the data you see
that again as good as the performance
for the body code we have extremely high
purity the mean is always higher than
95% the recoveries also extremely great
the lowest 12 656 this depending on the
lower frequency of the cells and
starting not here and for sure also the
years here coming out of one complete
and I see
you
we are able to do Auto from lrc
consecutive positive oscillations we
have the same markers as for Buffy cold
and we have open for sure on more and we
configured the kids again as for the
Buffy coat together with the microbeads
this kit contains LS columns and the
whole blunt elution buffer and as for
body code you would meet the cradle
marks and multi marker 24 or the
multi-max weeks for magnetic separation
to get your cells of interest so when we
are talking about all blood separation
the process here is as easy as for body
code and and see what we do here is we
simply add 50 microliters of microbeads
permit the whole blood for the magnetic
separation and after 50 minutes again we
go directly over one whole blood column
and for the direct enrichment of sense
also again no cell accounting no washing
needed without energy gradient
centrifugation the whole lot reagents
were developed already the wild goal so
the puget and recoveries are good as for
the other regions we have the larger
number of markers available the so
beside the markers 14 episodes that
toxic T cells B cells and then cases as
well as monocytes we also have markers
for the enrichment of marlott precursors
like CDs 33 or for granular sides like
CD 15 or CD 66 b and plasma cells like
CD 138
for the manual to full automation you
can use whole blood columns and you can
use the quarter marks than the media
marks for manual separation here we also
have special protocols for our automatic
pol fully automated device and you can
use them also for sure on the multi
marketer 24 and via the multi mark 6 so
let's have a look at some applications
so first let's have a look at these URLs
and you know what I want to show here is
the cd4 T helper cells which were
isolated directly from whole blood and
then stimulated or not with a - and T
cell activation and expansion kit and
what you see here is the expression of
the maturation marker CD 62 9 you see
that without a stimuli after on day 1
you don't see an increase so there's no
activation without any stimuli of the T
cells but you are able to stimulate them
using the activation and expansionary
agents to Express CD 69 at high level
and in the same level the expression of
C 60 to L decreases upon activation so
what we also did here on the right hand
I showed the analysis of cd8 positive
cytotoxic T cells which were directly
enriched from world blood and also
stimulated and what we did here was we
analyzed the secretion of interferon
gamma and TNF alpha so after two or six
hours stimulation and you can see that
without any stimuli we don't have any
cytokines we created so there's no
unspecific
activation of cells and upon stimulation
you see high increase of cells which
secrete the cytokines cd14 positive
monocytes is the next application I want
to talk about so Ross production is a
hallmark of monocytes and most
production cannot only cure after
stimulation like tll stimulation by RTS
or can also a cure independent of
stimulation this is something what you
can see here you see here confocal
microscope pictures staining with 12
rocks this is a semipermeable floor
genic probe so when what you see here on
the left hand you see the straight from
body coat c14 enriched monocytes and you
see Melrose production whereas on the
right hand
you see monocytes which were separated
by our agents from the vendor when you
first need to do cycles or meaning and
reach your monocytes untouched but from
a PMC fraction and you see here
immediately that there's an increase in
Ross production and this is reflected
here as well you see on the right hand
that the background of the Ross is
extremely high so that this lowers your
si sensitivity when we are talking about
analysis of brass production for
monocytes
you
let's have a look at the activation
markets expressed on visas and what you
see here b-cells and reached directly
from Buffy code using cd19 and
stimulated then for two days plus minus
c PG and you see here as we already had
for the t-cells expression of C 69 but
also the another marker of activation
for b-cells CD 86 and you see that
without simulation of cpg of the b-cells
you see no increase on this activation
markers where as in after the
stimulation you have a high increase off
of this marker
but we also analyzed via Elijah with the
analysis of immune globulin secretion of
visa and what you see here is the
secretion of IgG IgA and IgM into the
media after seven days or five days pre
incubation of them stimulation we're
with CPG and you see also that without
any stimulation there's no movable in
concentration within the media that can
be detected so last slide I want to show
you also again for research as plasma
blast differentiation and what you can
see here again is CD I suppose deserts
were isolated directly from Buffy called
the flow analysis was done for plasma
blast to analyze my lcd expression of CD
27 and cd38 so when the plasma blast
differentiation was done with a cocktail
of cd40 ligand CPG aisle to aisle 10 and
i-15 and then followed after a three-day
culture again with rather plus markup
further cocktail and plasma
differentiation was then done with iron
6:15 and Interphone alpha and so without
any stimuli you don't see any plasma
blast differentiation and this brings me
directly to the summary of our talk so
you see that with
we agents we develop the simple and half
adulation is possible from different
starting materials as holography code
and a sea of look apart
there's no need to do any density
gradient before you reach yourselves for
interest what's also extremely important
when you talk to people in the lab that
you don't need to adjust anything with
regard to the cell number so there's no
need to do cell counting before and you
we are extremely fast with our
separation meaning within thirty minutes
you have your sense of interest we're
talking about fishes Sanford's you can
also go for multiple subsets form the
single sample meaning you can do
consecutive separations and using the
multi marks this completes a package for
your semi automated cell isolation
process so then with that I thank you
for your attention I'm happy to take any
questions Thank You Jean and Gregor for
your presentations
a quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button zhangmu you and Gregor
winkles will answer as many questions as
time permits first question is the half
size leuco packs i usually receive are
only around 100 milliliters how should i
use them
this is rather easy you simply take your
sample and fill it up to 200 ml essence
we configured the grid that you can
simply fill your sample to 200
milliliters then add the microbe eat the
content of one vial and incubate 15
minutes and directly can go to enrich
your surface interest is the Buffy coat
kit available yes that's also possible
you can process also half or quarter of
the buffy when you use only half a
quarter the volume of the straight four
micro beads and the numbers of the
columns you need to decrease accordingly
thank you next one is up to how many
subpopulations can you isolate from one
single sample so what we've tried so far
was to go for three populations what we
tested was to start with starting with
cd14 and then cd8 and cd4 but I think it
would be also worth to give it a try to
do more we haven't tested it but in
principle it should bother your next
questions what other markers do you have
available
at the moment we have the ones that we
just showed we are working on a few more
markers but in case you have specific
needs you can also reach out to us and
we would love to hear your specific
marker wishes
it looks like we have time for one more
question it will be I am interested in
testing these beads
do you have samples available
so pests I can answer that question we
don't have a specific samples available
because we think this kid is shown the
best when it can be tested and but in
its whole using for example a complete
or a health off it code or Luca pack so
in that case I would say reach out to
your local Milton Lee representative or
contact us and we can see if we can have
a demo at your place with your specific
starting material and Marga I would like
to once again thank John you and Gregor
winkles for their presentations I'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration we would like
to thank our sponsor Milton E biotech
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through December 2018 lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye